[Musique]
super j'ai adoré c'est génial ils ont
fait un film démentiel j'en ai pris
plein les yeux
ah ben ça ça décoiffe ins et c'est
vraiment spectaculaire et sensationnel
dans le sens vraiment ça éveille tous
les sens et à beaucoup d'action très bon
film ouais vraiment les effets visuels
sont magnifiques les méchants cours sur
l'eau ils ont des requins fantôme
c est incroyable c'était fou mais ça
faisait très longtemps que j'attendais
un nouvel opus je suis vraiment une
grosse fan de la saga donc j'étais juste
super excitée à l'idée de voir et j'ai
vraiment pas été déçu
samassa ouais ça m'a beaucoup beaucoup
rappelé les tout premiers tiers des
caraïbes donc j'étais très content je
retourne dans l'enfance c'est très
marrant il ya une très bonne histoire
honnêtement moi j'ai passé un très bon
moment j'ai souhaité que la tâche était
bien contente de retrouver jack sparrow
et puis la 3d dingue
voilà moi j'ai trouvé sa grandiose c'est
peut-être même le meilleur de la saga
sera fidèle à l'histoire
c'était vraiment très bien j'aime par
dessus tout c'est qu'on passe par tous
les états c'est-à-dire le la peur le
suspense
et puis les vannes des traîtres très
bonnes vannes
on en prend plein franchement c'était
impressionnant et que du plaisir comme
d'habitude
[Musique]
les pirates infesté les maires depuis
des générations
je vis dans ses remords de les éliminer
dos c'est là qu'a paru ce gamin jack
sparrow
suivez le
mollo va tout ce que j'avais il
déclencha
ma fureur est mort ont pris le
commandement des sceaux s'est dit sergio
navy une fille et un pirate
on m'a conté la légende l'actuel
capitaine espagnol qui traqua et là des
milliers d'hommes ne dort pas des hommes
non des pirates des pirates
je viens connu un espagnol avec un en
espagnol
il en a après vous jack
où est votre bateau votre équipage
votre pantalon jack les excuses de quoi
on parlait déjà il peut plus cacher
trouve sparrow pour 1
à partir de maintenant nous sommes
alliés
vu les circonstances nous sommes bien
plus que ça
[Musique]
le macaque
ne veut pas avoir de problème
pat amusé tous les jours
berra pour ce qu'il m'a fait
c'est ça mon nom après jack je nagerai
jusqu'aux rives m'arrêter je vous en
prie non non on n'arrête pas vous allez
bien trop loin au bois du coup j'ai vu
ces filles d'en arriver bien plus si tu
avais fermer ton qu'à quai